- This is so cool.
I love Michelle Obama,
and she recently posted about you
saying that you are one
of her favorite comedians.
So how did that feel?
That's pretty rad.
Just to have fans in general,
but somebody like her
to notice, that's cool.
- It felt amazing.
She had actually reached out to me
a couple years ago and sent me a letter,
like a handwritten letter,
and it's framed in my house
where she wrote me about
how touched she was
that I talk about women's bodies
and what happens to our bodies
and make us laugh at the same time.
And she was like, "I think
that's really important."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, yeah, of course.
I mean, it's her.
- That's cool.
Yeah.
So it means the world to me.
- Yeah.
- And I have not yet to meet her.
She was before COVID, she was set to come
to one of my shows in DC
and I think she bought like 25 seats.
I'm sure half of them
were for Secret Service,
but whatever.
(Kelly laughing)
They paid for the tickets,
so I appreciate it.
- [Kelly] Regardless, yeah.
- Yeah.
And so I'm really, I hope
she comes this summer.
- Oh my gosh, you're so funny I cannot.